hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
i'm rachel smith in today's best picture
close-up flashback to the 70s as David
O'Russell and the stars of American
hustle show us what happens when feds
and con artists collide the movies not
only operatic and the music but I think
it's operatic in the emotions that's how
I think of all these workers this is
like a cinema of emotion and passion and
that's what it is it's great to have a
doozy of a predicament because that
gives me the opportunity and all of us
to let the characters do a very wide
range behavior that we can love and live
with you know the deeper the predicament
aboard amazingly will be their lives
I was just struck by how each of the
characters had such a fascinating and
personal connection with their clothes
they're all using clothes as part of
their household and by using clothes to
sort of dress as the people that they're
aspiring to be so the 70s palette gave
us so many great opportunities to
explore really Sidney's she is telling
such a story with the clothes and she it
seems like the less confident she feels
about the situation a less clothes she
wears it's like which happens with women
from time to time coming at it from a
character point of view and never felt
preterius it never felt to me it felt
like she was using it as a distraction
or manipulation or a middle finger to
her lover who brought his wife to the
party so she's like fine over this David
continues the writing interview to the
production he's still thinking like a
writer how to make the story better or
how to improve things it is a total
pleasure in the largest sense to do that
because we
all right you know there's a certain he
allows a certain freedom with people's
ideas to try them without sort of any
overhead or any baggage what's amazing
about these characters is that even
though they're big and they're operatic
and they go through these huge swings
they're also still very very relatable
and they have a tremendous amount of
soul and a tremendous amount of hope and
a tremendous amount of desire and that
encourages us to have those things in
our life and to pursue those things in
our life this isn't a film about a scam
this is a film about people and David
makes films about people and so I just
did I hope it opens people's eyes and
reminds me of people they know and that
they see themselves in these in these
films and recognize own how flawed and
human and funny they all are you know
even in earth even a nerd really was
pretty funny I want the combination of
the of the moviemaking the movement of
the camera the performances and the
music to combine for something that just
kind of is very propulsive and emotional
and original and that leaves you with an
exhilarating feeling because that's how
I feel and I say many times there's kind
of an exhilaration even if it's about
something that was in some ways tragic
there's an exhilaration and I mean I
guess the humanists and the survival of
love or hope and in a struggle or the
bracing miss or aliveness of the flow so
that's what I want is that
this another two girls what I have to do
if people feel that I feel happy now
that you know more about this Best
Picture nominee go to Oscar calm to fill
out your my picks ballot and share it
with your Facebook friends